It's showtime, y'all.
You love him and I love him.
Put your hands together.
Dolemite is my name!
Dolemite.
Auntie, I was thinking
about putting out
-a comedy record.
-Comedy?
You been a singer,
a Shake dancer...
It's real hard to break in.
I'll do whatever it takes
to get in.
I come up
with a new character.
Dolemite is my name,
and fuckin' up motherfuckers
is my game.
What you do to your hair?
You look like a pimp.
It's all pretend.
I just created a character.
-You a trip.
-Pull on that.
-That's a wig.
-A wig, that's right.
Whatever it takes,
I'm ready to do it.
I got to be totally outrageous.
It's filthy.
You've got a product here
that you can't sell
or promote.
All my life
people been telling me no.
Rudy, sometimes our dreams
just don't come true.
A man slam a door in my face,
I just find another door.
I want the world
to know I exist.
This ain't funny.
And it ain't no brothers
in it either.
If I get up in that light
with my own movie,
I could be everywhere
all at once.
Let's bring Dolemite
to the screen.
The actors we hire,
you're a bit doughier
than them.
Doughier?
That's D'Urville Martin.
I'm offering you a role
in my new motion picture.
You think you can just
walk up here and hire me?
-No.
-What if we let you direct?
In storytelling, it's always
best to write what you know.
Ain't nothing to talk about
in my personal life.
I deal with the nightlife.
Club owners and mobsters,
lots of pimps and kung fu.
-Do you know karate?
-No, but I'm a fast learner.
I can learn
how to chop me a mother--
Action.
-Dolemite, give it to me.
-Put your weight on it.
Pretending like
he could be a sex machine.
What planet is this cat on?
-Damn!
-This thing flops,
you're working for free
the rest of your life.
I'm so grateful
for what you did for me,
'cause I never seen nobody
that looks like me...
-Oh, yeah!
-...up there on that big screen.
God damn, Dolemite.
-Cut.
-Was it as good as Shaft?